Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
Today I'm going to do another
show in a series I like to
call "You're Doing It Wrong."
Now, the demo you're going to
see is not code that I would
like you to copy and paste.
In fact, it is code that
I would like you to
not copy and paste.
Don't do what I'm doing today.
Instead, it's a hacked up demo
to show an egregious example
of something that I have
seen commonly in other
applications.
And usually, the effect
is more subtle.
And being subtle, it takes a
long time for me to track down
the problem.
But it all boils down to one
single problem that a lot of
applications share, which is,
don't call Request Layout
during layout.
And let's take a look
at the demo.
And then I'll talk a little bit
about why this is a really
bad thing for your application
to do and a good thing for
your application to avoid.
So first of all, we
have this demo.
I have three simple
buttons there.
There's an Add and a
Remove button, and
then a Layout button.
When I click Add, it's
going to add a
button to the container.
So that button should
appear below.
When I Remove, it's going to
remove the first button in
that container if said
button exists.
And the Layout call
requests layout on
the container itself.
So it basically forces
a layout.
So first, I'll click Add.
And nothing happened.
But you'll see, actually
something did happen.
It's just that there was no
visual change to the activity.
So if I call Request Layout
forcibly on the container, you
can now see, oh, well that
button actually was there.
We just weren't seeing it.
Again, I can call Add again,
add another button.
And in fact I have to call
Request Layout to actually see
the button.
I can keep doing this
over and over again.
And each time we actually add a
button, but nothing happens.
Similarly, I can click
on the Remove.
And a button disappears.
But the container actually
should have shrunk around it.
And that simply didn't happen.
So if I call Request Layout,
the right thing happens.
Again, click Remove, the
button goes away.
But the right visual thing
didn't happen.
So let's take a look
at the code.
And then let's chat about what's
actually going on.
So here's my hacked up demo.
And again, this is not
necessarily the instantiation
of what I have seen
in applications.
But they all boil down to
essentially this logic, which
is, request layouts are getting
called somewhere--
either directly or
indirectly--
during the middle of
the layout process.
And that is the root
of the problem.
So in this particular hackey
demo, we have click listeners
on the buttons for the
Add View button.
We set a flag that says, hey,
I'd like you to add a view.
And then we call Request Layout
on that layout where
we're going to add the view.
Remove button-- similarly, we
set a flag that says, hey, I'd
like to remove one
of your views.
And then we call
Request Layout.
And then finally, the Layout
button forces a layout by
calling Request Layout
on that container.
And that restores the state that
we thought the container
should have been in when we
did the Add and Remove
operations.
Here's a custom container.
It has those couple
of flags in it.
And then it has this
On Layout override.
So On Layout is a standard
override from the View class.
So if you would like
to do something
special in your layout--
for instance, Linear Layout
overrides On Layout.
And that's where it actually
lays out its children
horizontally or vertically to
position them appropriately on
the screen before returning
from On Layout.
So in here, we say, OK, if
there's a Remove request
pending, then we're going to
call this method that says,
remove button.
And then, all we're going to do
is remove the first child,
if that child exists.
And if there's an Add request
pending, then we're going to
add a button.
And then we're going
to reset the flag.
And adding a button simply
creates this button along the
way, sets the layout parameters
accordingly, sets
some text on there so we know
which button it is.
And then we add the view.
So the actual code to remove
and add these views and set
the properties and the layout
params on all the views--
all of that's correct.
The problem is that we're
doing it in On Layout.
We're basically in the middle of
laying out the entire view
hierarchy, or some subset of it
that needed to be laid out.
And that's the time when we
actually call functions to add
and remove views, which
are going to
affect the layout itself.
So it's kind of a recursive
problem where we're in the
middle of doing something, and
we change properties that will
side effect the thing that
we are trying to do.
In particular, and here's the
crux of the problem, we're in
the middle of laying
out the container.
And so, for instance, we
call super.onLayout.
That's going to call up into the
code in Linear Layout that
figures out where all the
children should be.
And then, we're going to go
ahead and add or remove
children after that call.
And when layout is done for
any particular node in the
view hierarchy, it's going to
clear some flag saying, I'm
done with layout.
So what's going to happen is,
we're going to either add or
remove views in this code.
And then we're going to return
back to the superclass, the
actual Layout call
on the view.
And the view's going to say,
OK, I'm done with layout.
And then, it continues
along with its life.
Meanwhile, these guys have
been added here.
And they have not had the proper
side effect on the
sizing and positioning
information of that view.
So they have requested Layout,
which is a side effect of
calling Add or Remove view.
But that request didn't
propagate, because we're
already in the middle of doing
layout and figured we were
done when we finished
that Layout call.
So there are many different
ways to do this.
I have, in this demo,
picked probably the
worst way to do it.
The easiest way for you to
actually do this correctly in
this particularly hackey demo
is, instead of actually
setting a flag and then forcing
this thing to happen
within layout, the correct thing
to do would actually be,
for example, to call
myLayout.addButton
directly in that code.
Get rid of these horribly
offensive lines of code.
Similarly, remove button--
you could call
myLayout.removeButton and
get rid of this hackey
approach to doing it.
Now, this is rather obvious.
As I said, this is a hackey
demo that shows the most
obvious example of this.
But we've seen other things that
are quite similar to this
where, in the middle of
someone's measurement or
layout code, someone goes ahead
and does things that are
side effecting the stuff that
the entire view hierarchy is
in the middle of dealing with.
You will see an approach to this
in list view and adapter
view and some of the
internal classes.
And I've seen some custom
classes that do things
similarly externally, where the
correct approach, if you
really, for some reason, need
to do this in the middle of
that code, say you're
a list view and
you're recycling views.
And things do get added and
removed during layout.
One of the things you should
keep in mind is that there are
Add View in layout and Remove
View in layout.
These are the methods to call if
you're actually doing these
things during the middle
of layout.
But the most important thing
to remember is, when you
finish layout, all of the
measurement and layout
information for that container
should be done.
It should be complete.
Which means, if you're adding
children during the middle of
layout, you need to make sure
that your measurement
information and that of your
children is all correct by the
time you return from layout.
Because that's what the rest of
the view hierarchy expects.
So don't do it like I did it.
Actually do it correctly
instead.
And don't do this stuff
during layout.
Or if you do, do it
the correct way.
And make sure that when your
layout for your container
finishes, everything below it
is handled correctly so that
the view hierarchy is
in a consistent
state with your container.
Thanks.